Học thứ người, của hội phá mi làm sẽ bàn thào các đội dùng về sự an đoạn mắc chi sự đôi.
Lần sự đôi này tập trung vào bố nhóm chỉ sách lớn, tăng cường công phát quả lý đối với hoạt động mắc chi,
năng cao trên lượng người là báo, lấy gạo cơ quan mắc chi, thuộc đầy phát triển tinh tế mắc chi,
và điều trình hoạt động mắc chi trên không dành mạng. Theo bộng, các khí thào và suy định,
sự thào quy định cân mình tắc về mô hình hoạt động tinh tế mắc chi, mở giọc không dành hợp của báo chi,
để phát triển báo chi trong mối cảnh sắp, tinh gọi tổ chức mộ mái của hệ thông trí trị,
đáp ứng yêu cộng tinh tuyên trường trong kiến mi mới.
Như quy định được mô sông trong đó có tất quan trường thông chủ lực đáp phân tiệt,
là tất quan mắc chi có nhiều rãi hình báo chi, tất quan máo chi trực thuộc,
được có tất trế đặc tù về tài chính thạc quy định của chi phủ.
Mọi giống đáng chú ý khác là mô xuống quy định về mô thu mới của cơ quan báo chi,
mô mù thô từ mặt quyền xem tắc và báo chi,
từ cho phép khai thác sự dụng tắc và báo chi,
từ lên cách trong hòa lợc báo chi, bavan vật.
Tự thảo luật cũng mô xuống hoàn thiện mô xuống quy định,
nhằm tạo nhiều kiện cho tất quan báo chi có têm mồn thu,
tháng gớ khó khăn trong hòa lòng,
nhiều được nhá nước hỗ trợ đầu tư tài chính,
mở sộn mồn thu của cơ quan báo chi,
quy định về lên cách, hợp tắc,
quy định về còn cảo.
Dự á lợc báo chi sở đôi,
sẽ được chiến của hội xem xét,
thông qua tại khi học thứ người,
của hội khoảng 15,
sẽ giả từng em mới tháng 1 đến 1 tháng 2.